Oberyn Martell: "Unbowed, Unbent, Unbroken."
The words of House Martell.A promise to our
enemies and a challenge to our lovers.
Thousands of years ago, the warrior queen
Nymeria crossed into Dorne from Essos, fleeing
the dragonlords of Valyria.
After she landed, she burned her ships, all
ten thousand of them, so no cowards could
slink home.
What a woman.
Dornish in spirit before she ever was in flesh.
She was lucky to land in Dorne, where powerful
women are not locked away in septs and the
beds of old men.
My ancestor, Mors Martell, saw her and desired
her, and proved that where armies fail, a
tongue may succeed.
Wedding his strength to hers, his spear to
her sun, they subdued all of his rivals together.
After the tradition of her people, House Martell
then ruled Dorne as Princes, not kings, unless
the eldest child was a daughter.
For unlike the rest
of Westeros, we follow a Prince or a Princess
Martell just the same, and we always have.
Some people forget that Aegon Targaryen crowned
himself lord of six kingdoms, not seven.
When his sister marched on Dorne, she found
no mighty hosts drawn up against her for her
dragon to burn and her soldiers to slaughter.
The sands swirled, men died, and her dragon
saw nothing.
The sun shone, men died, and her dragon bowed
to our greater fire.
The Targaryens retreated with their tails
tucked between their legs.
Of course, in later years, his descendants
would try again.
Daeron the First succeeded at great cost and
reigned in Dorne for a few glorious months.
One night, his steward pulled down a sash
by his bed to summon his consorts.
Instead, the canopy split open, and a hundred
red scorpions fell on him.
He was a Tyrell.
You would think he would be used to getting
stung.
Within a fortnight, House Martell again ruled
a free Dorne.
Twice the Targaryens tried to conquer Dorne
with soldiers.
Twice they failed.
Only when the dragon kings came bearing husbands
and wives did my ancestors relent and agree
to join their Seven Kingdoms.
House Martell could have waged war until the
end of days, but how could we resist a peace
we could take to bed?
Eventually, after centuries of courtship,
House Martell got into bed with the Targaryens.
We took King Daeron II and his sister for
our own before they could take each other,
and six kingdoms became seven.
Even now, I do not blame my ancestors.
One look at those long silver locks.
It is not every day a man gets to ride a dragon.
Viserys Targaryen: After the submission of
House Stark, Aegon marches towards Oldtown,
steeling himself for another battle.
But he found the gates open, with the High
Septon welcoming him.
The pious fool even had the arrogance to grant
what Aegon had already won, and anointed the
last Valyrian as "Aegon of House Targaryen,
First of His Name, King of the Andals and
the First Men, Lord of the Seven Kingdoms
and Protector of the Realm."
Varys: But while Aegon titled himself Lord
of the Seven Kingdoms, in reality, he held
only six.
The seventh, Dorne, had never knelt.
Visenya had flown into the Vale and returned
with its crown.
Mimicking her sister, Rhaenys had flown over
the enemy force holding the passes into Dorne
and landed in the castle of its ruling lady,
Princess Meria of House Martell.
Meria was eighty years old, fat, bald, and
blind.
Behind her back, many sniggered at her as
the "Yellow Toad of Dorne."
The beautiful Rhaenys probably thought as
much when they met.
She demanded Princess Meria kneel to her brother
Aegon, though she allowed that on account
of Meria's age and health, a simple vow of
submission would do.
But the princess told the queen that the Targaryens
weren't wanted in Dorne, and no Martell would
ever bow, bend or break no matter how badly
they burned.
Rhaenys could have mounted her dragon right
then, and roasted Meria in the castle as her
brother had done at Harrenhal.
But whatever she saw in Meria's eyes scared
her right back to King's Landing, with a dragon's
tail between its legs.
After Aegon's coronation, Rhaenys returned
to Dorne with Aegon and Visenya and their
dragons.
But no armies met them in the field, and no
lords defied them in their castles.
As the dragons approached, Dorne simply emptied.
House Martell had learned from Harrenhal and
the Field of Fire.
The dragons were unbeatable in battle, but
wars were more than battles.
Unopposed, Aegon claimed Dorne for his own.
But as soon as he returned to King's Landing,
his castellans were hurled off towers, and
his royal garrison vanished in the desert,
never to be seen again.
Except, perhaps, when the winds change and
the sands cough up old bones and armor.Rhaenys
returned on Meraxes, intent on avenging herself
against Meria Martell.
But Dorne was no longer empty.
The Dornish kept Meria's promise and fought
even while burning under dragon flame.
And they won.
One day a bolt pierced the eye of Meraxes
and knocked the dragon out of the sky.
House Martell remained unbroken, unlike the
unfortunate Rhaenys.
In their wrath, Aegon and Visenya set flame
to every castle and city but Sunspear, trying
to turn the people against House Martell.
But the Dornish stayed loyal, and when Aegon
returned to King's Landing, he found assassins
waiting for him in the streets of his own
capital.
If not for Visenya, the Conqueror would not
have enjoyed his conquest for very long.
From then on, the king and his family would
be guarded by the seven greatest knights in
the realm: the Kingsguard.
When Meria died in her sleep, a weak and tired
son sued for peace.
But old Meria had exhausted Aegon as well,
and he granted the request.
The Targaryens still wanted Dorne, and eventually,
they would have it, but not at the point of
a sword.
They would buy it the same way great lords
buy anything: with a daughter.
Ellaria Sand: Before the Seven Kingdoms, before
the Iron Throne, there was Dorne.
Twelve thousand years ago, the First Men crossed
the land bridge from Essos to here.
Of course, they were men, so they soon broke
it.
Then, while their cousins to the North built
kingdoms, the Dornish squabbled over land,
water, and wives for centuries.
Until Nymeria, a warrior princess in Essos.
She led a fleet of ten thousand ships across
the Narrow Sea to Dorne.
Almost all of the petty lords made it clear
that she wasn't welcome.
All but one.
Mors of House Martell.
He saw in her a strength to match any man,
including his rivals.
After she accepted his marriage offer, she
set fire to her ships.
For fifty leagues, the coast was bright as
day, and in the burning light, Princess Nymeria
named Mors Martell the Prince of Dorne, in
the style of her people.
Dorne would be her home or her grave.
For many years, Nymeria and Mors waged war
against all rivals.
The Jordaynes, Blackmonts, Qorgyles, and even
the mighty House Yronwood.
They sent no fewer than six self-styled "kings"
to the Wall in golden chains.
After Mors fell in battle, Nymeria took command
of his armies and united Dorne in two years.
She ruled for twenty-seven more, and though
she married again, those husbands were little
more than councilors and consorts.
Dorne was Nymeria, and Nymeria was Dorne.
She survived a dozen attempts on her life,
put down two rebellions, and threw back two
invasions.
And when at last, she died, her eldest child
succeeded her (her daughter, not her son),
and Dorne followed her because Nymeria had
proven that women were equal to men, if not
better.
Centuries later, Aegon Targaryen sought to
unite Westeros, as Nymeria had Dorne.
The other six kingdoms fell quickly before
his dragons and ambition.
When his sister-wife, Rhaenys, flew her dragon
south and demanded Dorne's surrender as well,
Princess Meria Martell warned, "I will not
fight you, nor will I kneel to you.
Dorne has no king.
Tell your brother that."
Rhaenys threatened that the next time the
Targaryens would come with fire and blood.
Meria replied, "You may burn us, my lady,
but you will not bend us, break us or make
us bow.
This is Dorne; you are not wanted here.
Return at your peril!"
Rhaenys did, and she died.
Her dragon died.
All her soldiers died.
Eventually, her brother, the Conqueror, conceded
that what Nymeria had done, he could not undo.
Generations later, another foolish Targaryen
invaded Dorne.
He died as well.
Eventually, we did join the Seven Kingdoms,
but when we wanted and on our terms.
If dragons could not conquer us, why should
we fear lions?
"Unbowed, unbent, unbroken."
The words of House Martell.The words of Dorne.
Men may forget, but women always remember.
When we were divided, Nymeria united us.
When we were invaded, Meria defended us.